so you're a wealthy businessman from
china you've worked hard to build an
empire for yourself so you can escape
the poor peasantry
and now that you finally made it it is
time to live the good life
you want the best education for your
children a clean living environment
maybe even surprise your wife with a new
luxury car but there is just one problem
you're still living in china under a
super dangerous government the chinese
communist party also known as the ccp
if you step out of line if you say one
wrong word or if you just enjoyed life a
little too much you may disappear like
all the other chinese billionaires who
dropped off the face of the earth one of
the guys said jack in 10 years we will
have a fantastic memorial for you thank
alibaba giacomo for doing these great
things but now we have to kill you
you've worked so hard how are you
supposed to enjoy life and raise a
family if you're always looking around
your shoulder for the ccp you don't want
your children to fall prey to the
brainwashing that happens inside of
chinese schools you and your family
deserve better than that so it's time to
move to a country like the us where you
can enjoy all the freedom in the world
but then you run into another problem
you can't just buy a first class plane
ticket and move into a fancy mansion in
beverly hills just like that it is not
that easy
see the ccp is smart they know living
under their world sucks and they also
know that their subjects that do get
rich will want to take their money and
move out of the country which would hurt
their economy their power among other
things
so they put measures in place to prevent
that from happening
see if you want to leave china once and
for all you must first get your million
dollar fortune out of the country but
thanks to china's 50 000 yearly limit of
how much money you can move out of the
country it would take decades to get
your fortune out china and you simply
don't have that much time and if you
leave your money in china while you
leave the ccp might freeze your bank
account to keep you on a short leash
after all it's not like you earned all
your money cleanly
in an environment like china bribing an
official here and there is just a part
of the game you have to play you had to
resort to dirty tricks maybe even some
corruption here and there top chinese
official has been charged with accepting
bribes stealing state secrets and
abusing his power
which means the ccp has plenty of dirt
on you that they can press charges for
whenever they please
that's why you always see people who go
up against the government go down for
corruption charges in countries like
china and russia
but what if i told you that there was a
solution to all this a great systematic
way to funnel your money out of china as
soon as possible so you can get out from
under the ccp's chokehold and live
happily ever after in the west
my name is jake tran i make
documentaries on money power war and
crime with my team subscribe for more
and this is macau the las vegas of china
also known as the money laundering
capital of asia
becoming wealthy like these rich chinese
citizens takes a lot of skills people
skills business skills marketing skills
and much more and you can learn a lot of
these skills on skillshare skillshare is
an online learning community with
thousands of courses that allow you to
discover and explore your passions after
all the people making the most money are
the ones with the best skills and
skillshare can help you learn all those
skills right now no matter what topics
you're interested in you will find it on
skillshare there are just so many unique
and interesting courses like starting a
successful side hustle by youtuber ali
abdul or productivity for artists or
personal branding crafting your social
media presence i would personally start
off by taking real productivity how to
build habits that last by youtuber and
author thomas frank it teaches you
everything you need to know about
setting and reaching realistic goals so
you can do anything you put your mind to
there are a ton of experts teaching on
skillshare right now skillshare is
always pointing out new useful courses
and you'll never be distracted by ads or
interruptions during your class plus the
entire course catalog is now available
with subtitles in spanish french
portuguese and german the first 1 000
people to use the link skillshare.com
jake or my code jake tran will get a one
month free trial of skillshare that's
skillshare.com has jake with the link
below to start learning on skillshare
today thanks to skillshare for
sponsoring this video
[Music]
in the 16th century portugal was one of
the world's most dominant powers thanks
to their superior naval fleet and
military power they were already
building colonies in south america and
africa but now it was time to get a
foothold in asia in 1557 the ambitious
portuguese took over macau a tiny
peninsula in southern china making it
europe's first ever colony in east asia
the chinese called it ama gao in honor
of amma the goddess of the sea so the
portuguese simply called it macau and
for more than a century macau was the
main trading spot between asia and the
rest of the world
ships from italy portugal and spain came
there to buy and sell chinese silks
chinese tea indian spices african ivory
and brazilian gold business was booming
but then macau and the portuguese had to
face a new rival the british empire
during the 18th century the british had
an opium trade going with china's qing
dynasty more and more chinese were
smoking british opium as a recreational
drug and it had a devastating effect on
china's society because once you're
addicted to opium there's almost no
escape chinese citizens who tried to get
away from the drug suffered from chills
and nausea and sometimes even died from
withdrawal when the leaders of the qing
dynasty saw that opium was tearing
china's society apart they banned the
drug and put a stop to the opium trade
between the british and china but the
chinese people still wanted opium and
the british weren't going to let a
simple ban come between them and their
prophets so they started smuggling opium
into china under the nose of qing's
leadership the qing dynasty's response a
crackdown on the british opium trade
they seized british ships destroyed
thousands of tons of opium by mixing it
with lime and salt and dumping it into
the bay and they arrested hundreds of
chinese dealers it was a declaration of
war
in 1839 the british army invaded china
to secure their opium business then the
british thought to themselves well we're
already at war with the chinese we might
as well take over one of these port
cities while we're at it and build a
colony there so they took control over
hong kong right on the other side of the
bay from macau now on one side of the
bay lay the portuguese colony and on the
other side of the bay laid the british
colony
after the british won the opium war they
controlled most trading routes in east
asia and macau's influence started to
wane at the expense of the portuguese
but the portuguese weren't going to give
up that easily they just had to find a
new source of revenue so in 1849 they
made a decision that would change macau
forever they legalized gambling since
gambling was illegal in mainland china
more and more people flocked to macau to
try their luck and it would soon turn
macau into the gambling capital of the
world due to a treaty with the qing
dynasty the portuguese thought they
would control macau forever but by 1999
the chinese communist party was in full
control of china and portugal had become
a shell of its former colonial self and
the ccp were having none of that so
portugal surrendered control of macau
back to china but there was just one
condition
china could not interfere with macau's
gambling policy and china agreed macau
became the only place in all of china
where gambling and casinos were legal
and they went all in on this lucrative
vice
special deals were made with las vegas
kingpins luxurious casinos were built
and millions of people began to spend
their hard-earned money in asia's sin
city today macau is las vegas on
steroids in 2016 macau's revenue was 28
billion dollars three times more than
las vegas but where does all that money
actually come from you may think that
most of it comes from everyday gamblers
and tourists who try their luck in loud
casino halls but you would be mistaken
the majority of macau's gambling revenue
comes from its vip clients china's
wealthy elite who have found that macau
is a great way to get their money out of
china
[Music]
[Applause]
so
[Music]
macau's casinos work with businesses
called junkets junket is a very strange
sounding word so just think of a junket
like a club promoter but instead of
trying to get girls to come to a
nightclub junkets try to get wealthy
business people to go gamble in a macau
casino notice the air quotes around the
word gamble so naturally it's usually
run by very shady people who are often
times connected to the chinese triads
the casino hires the junket on
commission and the junket hires an agent
or promoter inside mainland china that
promoter will then find you a wealthy
businessman who wants to get his money
out of china and what does he offer you
a fancy vip package it includes a flight
to macau on a private jet a few nights
in one of macau's finest hotel rooms and
let's say
one million dollars worth of casino
chips for you to start with you pay the
promoter the one million plus dollars
from your chinese bank account wink wink
because you want to enjoy a fancy
weekend in macau nothing more definitely
not trying to escape the ccp
but there's a catch
you can exchange those chips for cash
right away that would be too easy too
obvious that this is money laundering so
the chips you get are so-called
non-negotiable chips you actually have
to travel to macau and gamble with them
but all the chips you win back are
negotiable chips which you can exchange
for cold hard cash that is outside of
the ccp's grasp
so you fly out to one of macau's fancy
casinos take a seat in the vip room far
away from the noisy gaming floors below
and you play a few hands of baccarat you
win some you lose some and once you've
played away your non-negotiable chips
you've hopefully won back most of your
money in the form of negotiable chips
wink wink and now you're free to cash
those chips for whatever currency you
want including the mighty us dollar
you want that money fair and square
outside of mainland china so you can do
whatever you want with it and voila
you've successfully circumvented the
pesky 50k dollar transfer limit
you see what we did there you had one
million dollars you wanted to get out of
china you paid that one million dollars
to a jughead promoter guy plus extra for
the flight hotel and cut for the junket
you got back 1 million dollars worth of
chips that you have to spend at the
macau casino you play those chips to get
back your money in exchangeable chips
and then you could finally exchange
those chips back into us dollars that
you can take anywhere you want the
junkyard got their commission so they're
happy the casino got their cut so
they're happy and you got your money out
of china albeit in a convoluted way and
for a fee but you're also happy do that
a few times and your million dollar
fortune will be safe in a bank account
of your choice far away from the
watchful eyes of the ccp
but as you can probably guess the
chinese government doesn't like seeing
these shady deals at all
for one they lose control over you once
you and all your money is out of china's
financial system they no longer have a
lot of leverage against you if you start
spreading nasty rumors about the ccp
they can't freeze your bank account
anymore if they want to arrest you for
let's say corruption you're out of reach
sure they can still try to hunt you down
in the u.s but since you're no longer on
chinese soil it's way more complicated
now the second problem is that huge
amounts of money are flowing out of
china's economy so the question is why
doesn't the ccp just shut these junket
operations down
well from a legal perspective it's a
gray area
selling fancy vip packages to rich
chinese is perfectly legal and all the
money they win in macau is revenue
outside the chinese system so
technically no one is breaking the law
besides these vip clients are the
backbone of macau's gambling industry
without them the city would collapse and
that would make china look really bad
especially since they're working so hard
to look like a legitimate country and
the next world superpower but now it
seems like the chinese government is
running out of patience
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
in late 2021 the real crackdown on
junkyat operations began with the arrest
of macau's junket king alvin chao
chao is the ceo of sun city macau's
largest junket operation during his
climb to the top chao became friends
with macau's organized crime boss a man
called broken tooth koi who at one point
got him a loan of about 3.8 million
dollars it was the beginning of his junk
head empire
sun city became macau's largest junk
head operator with about 12 000 agents
and a 40 market share it was a monopoly
every single casino in macau had a vip
room devoted to sun city's high roller
guests and alvin chao became macau's
superstar with an estimated net worth of
around 1.8 billion dollars all from
helping rich chinese get their money out
of china but in november 2021 it all
came crashing down
chao was arrested over his alleged
connections to cross-border gambling and
money laundering schemes within two
weeks his business was shut down sun
city closed all of its vip gaming rooms
in macau's casinos and shortly after
casinos like the win followed their lead
and closed all junket rooms entirely
in january 2022 macau's police struck
yet again the target
the ceo of macau's second biggest junk
head operator
chanwen ling the charge alleged money
laundering
as a result shares of his company macau
legend fell by more than 20
and chan resigned to avoid distraction
to the company with its two biggest
players arrested macau's junket industry
is not looking good and to make things
even more difficult it's now illegal to
entice mainlanders to gamble abroad
depending on the amount of money
involved you might even end up in jail
until recently the vip industry made up
more than two-thirds of macau's gambling
revenue but now the ccp is putting an
end to these operations once and for all
so china's wealthy elite are now back at
the drawing board desperate to find a
new way to get their money out of china
then hey who knows if you're watching
this in china right now with a vpn and
you know of a clever way to get money
out of china maybe you can be the next
money-laundering chinese billionaire
although
i probably wouldn't wish that on you
and if you want to get a free stock yes
a free stock with anywhere from three to
a thousand dollars all you have to do is
go to public.comtrend and create an
accounts public is a social stock
trading app that is a serious game
changer because you can follow other
investors right in the app to learn what
they invest in giving you a huge
competitive advantage so go to
public.com to get a free stock with the
link below thanks the public for
sponsoring this video
it has been a while since we made a
china video so let me know what you guys
thought in the comments if you're new
here my name is jake and this is one of
the biggest channels for documentaries
on money power war and crime we make
multiple documentaries every single week
for free so if you enjoyed this one
click that subscribe button below and if
you want longer documentaries are too
controversial to post publicly click
that join button below if you join and
you don't think it's worth it there's a
refund policy too so you can just email
me and i will personally refund you the
money you can follow me on instagram
jaytran for that chance to win a
thousand dollars we use a random
follower picker thing to make sure it's
actually random but that's gonna wrap it
up stay dangerous out there and i will
see you guys in the next
you